welcome everyone you're almost
graduating from the boot camp uh just
four more hours to go um
we have the same format as in all the
other days we'll go for an hour and then
have a break
welcome also to those of you on zoom um
i already sent the slide link there as
well i'll repost it again in a few
minutes
um
for those of you in the room since we're
in person again just raise your hand and
chandler will call on you if you can
just speak up the microphones in the
ceiling will pick you up and so that the
people on the call can hear you and if
you can if it's quiet you could briefly
repeat the question that would be
great so first day we talked about
graphical models the second day
we talked about causal discovery the
third day about potential outcomes and
so today on
our last day we're going to hear about
experimental design um after that we've
of course covered all of causal
causality that there could possibly be
and there's nothing else to be said so
you will have fully learned everything
there is of course not there's much more
and we've had to leave out a lot of
stuff that we can't cover in the boot
camp but that's what we've got the rest
of the semester for in any case
thank you very much to chandra squires
who's a grad student at mit and computer
science for taking this last day through
the uh um experimental design over to
you chandra thanks
great yeah and thank you to all the
organizers
especially for having me talk today
about this it's a really fun topic so i
hope i convey some of my enthusiasm for
it
and just kind of as a brief note before
we begin i'm gonna mostly be talking
about experimental design for
causal discovery or causal structure
learning so kind of the same goal of
learning a causal graph as we had on day
two
and in particular picking interventions
in order to learn this causal graph so
that
we can kind of fully identify the system
um
and this is just a brief outline of kind
of how i want to structure the day
may or may not stick exactly to this
division of things but i'm thinking in
the first hour
we'll go through some of the settings
uh the aspects of the different settings
that you might be doing experimental
design in
and really kind of nail down and clarify
those so that we understand what
settings each of the different
algorithms are going to be operating in
then we'll do some preliminaries uh that
kind of builds on
some of the stuff that we built on uh
the first and second day in terms of
what sort of information can be learned
from interventions
um in the second block i'll talk about
non-adaptive experimental designs
um and i'll kind of more formally
clarify that a little bit later on but
that's essentially things where you
decide the whole experimental design all
the interventions that you want to do
at one point in time um and that's to be
contrasted with adaptive experimental
design strategies which i'll discuss in
the third block where you get to observe
the outcome of each of your
interventions before picking a new
intervention
and then i'll finish up with
some areas where there's more open
challenges so things like targeted
experimental design where the goal is
not specifically
structure discovery learning kind of the
whole causal graph maybe learning part
of it or learning a certain
aspect of it that you are interested in
as well as a few other open challenges
um so getting started off with part one
um
the examples and kind of
aspects of the problem setting are going
to be largely motivated by
uh settings in genomics
so you can imagine inside of a cell
there are a bunch of genes that all
regulate each other and
uh for the sake of assumption we'll
assume that these are uh actually
following a dag model um which is you
know the stuff that we've been working
with pretty much throughout this week um
and
the types of interventions that we can
do on this and genomics we have these
great tools for knocking genes out so
you can essentially think of this as an
intervention where their value is set to
zero and we'll go through some of the
subtleties of the actual experiments
um and
how knockouts are actually
um kind of affect the data generating
process but from a very high level just
think of it as setting a gene equal to
zero
and here i have you know we have these
four genes you could have
two to the four different experiments if
your only
ability is to
intervene and knock something out so you
could do
any of the kind of single gene
experiments
or any of the two gene experiments or
three gene experiments or foraging
experiments
this is kind of the most general setup
um and the question we'll be asking
ourselves is how do we pick experiments
to learn the underlying puzzle graph
um and you know we could probably just
uh
intervene on every single thing
individually
that's not going to kind of be the most
efficient thing so as
we're going to be looking at kind of
different notions of efficiency or
optimality of the experiments that we
want to pick
so i'm going to go through some of the
kind of limitations that you may or may
not encounter in different experimental
designs now
so as i
discussed earlier the kind of
yep sorry
basic super basic what does it mean to
knock out a gene and what is the meaning
of an arrow from one gene to another
what
how does it cause
yeah so
i'm going to take the kind of view of
not explaining the biology here but
explaining just a kind of structural
causal process of we imagine a computer
program where
a value is sampled for the first orange
gene and then
you go down kind of the causal dag and
each of the
things below it you
sample the value from a distribution
that's conditional on its parents
and knocking out is just going to be
replacing a line in that program with
uh setting the value to zero
so
uh it's a binary kind of intervention
yeah i'm going to go into uh kind of
distinctions between different types of
interventions and few slides
but i think this is the easiest thing to
keep in mind this binary thing
so the
highest level distinction is between a
non-adaptive experimental design where i
said okay maybe i'm gonna do this
knockout on the orange jean and then i'm
gonna do a knock up on the blue and
green
at the same time
um
other ways that you could phrase this
and that you'll see in the literature
i guess you won't see single round in
literature but you could think of this
as being a single round of picking
interventions
you'll see passive um because you know
you only get to do something
once and then kind of the rest of the
data that you gather you just kind of
gather in a passive way after making
that one decision
uh you could call it parallel because
it's all happening you know these don't
actually have to have to happen at the
same time but they could happen at the
same time you could be assigning you
know three grad students or two grad
students in this case to be running
these experiments you know during the
same week
um or batch kind of similar um and then
the final terminology
uh to take note of is calling this just
a fixed experimental design where you
fix it ahead of time
this contrast with adaptive experimental
design where
you
say knock out the orange gene
see the outcome on your data
and then after that you decide what
intervention to do next so maybe in this
case you'd make the same decision you
initially made but you're making it with
more information
so
you could call this to contrast a single
round you could call this multi-round
intervention design
contrast with
passive you could call it active
um and then you'll also see this called
sequential so this is kind of more of
the sequential decision game problem
um that people might be familiar with
from bandits
so this is the highest level distinction
i expect to you know kind of see this in
an abstract or like kind of look for it
that's the first thing that i'll try to
identify
the next thing would be
um whether
the set of experiments that i'm
considering is unbounded so i can
intervene on as many things as i want to
at the same time or if it's bounded this
could be either because of
some technological
uh
kind of constraint where you have to
only intervene on a single gene at a
time say in knockout experiments or even
a kind of constraint like oh if you
intervene on
all the cells and knock them out or all
the genes and knock them out the cell's
going to die and you're not going to be
able to gather data from it so there are
kind of practical limitations in terms
of the number of experiments the number
of intervention targets that you might
be inside of each intervention
the next thing i'll distinguish between
is whether we're working with a fixed
budget
so you can kind of think of this as an
optimization problem and we'll fill in
kind of what we might mean by these
different terms but where you're trying
to maximize the amount of info
that your information about the system
that you're gaining from your
interventions
under a fixed budget where you keep the
cost of the interventions lower than the
budget usually people will
consider
each intervention costing the same
amount so you're just trying to keep the
size your number of interventions below
a fixed amount but you can also assign
costs to specific interventions and try
to keep the total below some amount
and this is to contrast with you know if
i just had a big pile of money and i say
i want to
completely identify the system i have
some sensitivity you know i i do care
about how much it costs so i'm going to
minimize the cost but
uh there's no kind of budget i'll keep
going and i'll keep experimenting until
i completely identify the underlying
causal system so this would be like a
minimum cost identification setting
this is what a lot of the work is going
to be focused on
and then the final experimental
limitation or kind of detail that i'll
incorporate um into this picture is uh
whether or not that there's
observational data available before so
if there's no observational data if you
just say
oh i've never seen this cell type before
um and you have to go out and
figure out
what the connections between all of the
genes and the cell type are
um you start with these dashed lines are
supposed to mean you know you kind of
start with no information it could be
anything it could be that they're not
there they could be oriented in either
direction
whereas if you start with observational
data say infinite amount of
observational data this will pinpoint
you down to at least the markov
equivalence class so this is something
that we talked about
on
uh day one and day two that from
observational data you can at least get
um if you recall it was the adjacencies
between the different
uh
genes in this case or the variables more
generally
as well as v structures so
the true causal graph was the one that
we had on
the slide before there were no
unshielded colliders no immoralities so
you would just get these adjacencies and
you'd be starting with
that type of information
so is everything about kind of the setup
and these binary kind of distinctions
clear so far
so um i'll kind of
keep this table
kind of going throughout and highlight
which setting each of these different
algorithms are in
um we're also going to i'm just going to
add these additional assumptions not as
kind of a binary thing because pretty
much all of the algorithms that we're
going to talk about in the first three
parts will
be in a specific
um kind of regime of this so
a lot of algorithm design starts by
considering the noiseless setting that's
what we're going to be focusing on today
so
you can imagine
like i said with the observational data
essentially you have enough samples
that you're pretty confident
that it's as well as like having
infinite samples
that you can tell the markov equivalence
class
and then
from each of your interventions you know
your intervention is kind of strong
enough you obtain enough samples
that you
uh kind of completely identify
everything that can be identified with
that intervention there's no uncertainty
left outside of kind of pure problems of
unidentifiability
between different models
um and we'll talk in the kind of fourth
part about how to relax that
and what what people do uh kind of the
way that you can think about it now
if it bothers you is that
uh similar to like kind of the
definition of algorithms uh that we had
in the causal structure discovery
lecture where we
kind of framed it in terms of
conditional independence oracle
uh you can think of what we have as a
what i'm calling a conditional and
variance oracle that allows you to tell
whether
a conditional distribution like
one node conditioned on some other set
is the same between
two of the kind of interventional data
sets
that you have
and in practice
similar to like how in practice with the
causal structure discovery you would be
doing hypothesis testing you can imagine
doing hypothesis testing on whether or
not these two conditional distributions
are equal
and
like kind of a
naive thing that you might initially
start by doing is just setting a
threshold epsilon
where you're going to
keep running and obtaining enough
interventional samples from each of your
interventions so that you can
distinguish any two distributions
that are further than epsilon under this
measure
and under some measure total variation
distance
um so yeah throughout
uh like maybe try to save the questions
for like stuff about the noisy setting
until later on um
and then we're also going to be
considering causally sufficient settings
um so settings without latent
compounding this is kind of the focus of
the first half of the causal structure
discovery lecture
so we're going to see what we can do
with this
now somebody asked about knockdown
interventions this is a type of
intervention in genomics where you
decrease the
expression of a cell but
of a certain gene in a cell but it might
still depend on
its parents in some way
um you've just kind of
uh
decreased the total dependence on its
parents
and
you know this is a real practical
problem uh in
different
experimental design settings
that not every intervention kind of
looks like this idealized intervention
where you just set a variable to some
value
and because of you know the
history of this do calculus and the
notation of do we're going to call these
new interventions there's other names
for them out there um
a little bit more general type of
intervention is one that still cuts a
variable off from its parents so at the
top we kind of see what's happening to
the graph
but instead of
setting it deterministically to some
predetermined value that you set you
might be setting it to some distribution
and these are called perfect
interventions
so you can imagine in the knockdown
experiment maybe you actually do remove
the dependence on the appearance or
something but there's still a little bit
of noise like this gene might end up
just randomly getting transcribed
despite none of its kind of parents like
telling it to be transcribed
and then kind of the most general type
of intervention is a going to be called
a soft intervention
or a mechanism change if you think of
this line as kind of the causal
mechanism which generates x2
so this allows you to retain
dependence on
your parents but it just changes it so
you know if you're in a linear model
this could be something like cutting all
of the coefficients in half or just
adding a shift and like you know
taking something down by
one or two or however many
kind of units
um
and for our purposes in this talk these
interventions or these types of
interventions are essentially going to
be equivalent
so
i'm going to define here
uh the types of identifiability that you
can get from different interventions i'm
going to do it through this lens of
interventional augmented graph so
if we have a causal system
x1 to x2 is like kind of the top
observational system
and then on the bottom we've changed the
mechanism that's generating x2
we can represent this
if we still think in terms of structural
causal models
by a
indicator variable this zeta 1 that's
telling
x2 essentially which of these
distributions to take its value from so
it's a zero one variable
if it's one then
uh this should actually
yeah if it's one then it's going to take
from
the interventional distribution if it's
zero it's going to take from the
observational distribution
and if we have multiple
um intervention variables or different
interventions we'll just add one for
each of the intervention variables or
for for each of the interventions so
zeta 1 will be corresponding to the
intervention i1
and we'll just add
between each of the
intervention variables that we introduce
uh an edge to the targets of that
intervention
and we're going to call this the
interventional dag
or
idag so throughout you know this kind of
can get confusing at first glance uh
when
we have
a set of interventions and each of these
if we're just defining it by its
intervention targets kind of forgetting
the information about
um whether this was a do intervention or
perfect intervention or a perfect
intervention or soft intervention
then
this is going to be a collection of sets
so this calligraphic i is always a
collection of sets in my notation
and it defines this interventional dag
according to this construction
right so
uh this kind of construction is
maybe a bit more recent way of viewing
like what interventions are doing to a
system and obtaining facts about uh
markov equivalent center interventions
and stuff like that
um
so talking about markov equivalents
the original definition that we had for
an observational
distribution was that
a
single distribution was markov to a
graph if
um there's many kind of equivalent
characterizations but one thing that we
said was that it factorized according to
that graph so
you can write out the distribution over
the variables as
a product of each of the variables given
its parents the conditional distribution
of each variable given its parents
so we're going to define a similar
notion for now an indexed set of
distributions where we get one
distribution for each intervention
so the first requirement is that each
distribution individually is still
markov with respect to the graph
this is kind of a sensible one we're not
breaking the mark off property when we
do an intervention we might be breaking
other things like we discussed
faithfulness we're doing a do
intervention it doesn't have to be
faithful to the original graph but it's
still going to factorize according to
the original graph this is
basically
due to the constraint even in soft
interventions that the function the
variable is still a function of its
parents
and not other variables
um and then furthermore we're going to
impose this constraint that's basically
just saying what we mean by
uh the system staying the same between
different interventions
so if we have some variable x i
that isn't in either of the
interventions the kth intervention or
the k prime
intervention
then
the mechanism that generates it so the
conditional distribution of that
variable given its parents
has to remain the same
um
similar you know we'll build up from
this definition of a set of
distributions being
i markov with respect to a graph
to the notion of an imark of equivalence
class
so
two dags are going to be imarkov
equivalent if
every index set of distributions which
is i mark up to one of them is also i
mark off to another so if you think of
this
as a set of distributions these two sets
are equal
and then i'll introduce some notation i
don't
believe we've used before so
um we'll be needing to
kind of keep track of
markov equivalents information
throughout a lot of our algorithms
so this is kind of shorthand notation
tells us
what the i mark of equivalence class of
a graph is so we'll have these brackets
and then subscript with what the
interventions are
and then in the interventional case i'm
just going to not have a subscript and
just use the brackets or in the
observational keys
any questions so far
so we'll start off with uh you know we
had this graphical characterization of
markov equivalents that
was
useful for us for many different things
in the
observational setting we also have a
graphical characterization in the
interventional setting so
we can basically
extend the notion of
having the same skeletons and same b
structures
just to the interventional graphs
um so the graphs of these augmented
interventional variables um in this
saying that the two dags are
[Music]
i mark of equivalent to each other if
and only if these graphs
still have the same skeletons and b
structures
maybe a little bit more informative way
to see this for our purposes of like
asking you know what information do we
learn from an intervention
is
to think of
um kind of what new v structures each
intervention will introduce
so all right an example
over here
if we have
a graph like this
and say we intervene on
x
2 so i'll add this 0 to 1 variable
right so we introduce a
uh b structure between these two
distributions here if you think about
this in terms of conditional
independence this is saying
x1
is independent
of
this is zeta one
uh or yeah it's not independent of the
theta one given x two
right so this is
um
or the they are d connected so generally
this is going to be saying that um
if we kind of interpret this as this
zero one variable that tells us what uh
setting that we're in it's saying that
um under this intervention
the conditional distribution of x1 given
x2
is not going to be equal to
the
observational distribution
of x1 given x2
um so if you think about you know this
being say a perfect intervention
um this is pretty clear that uh if
previously x1
depended on x2 now we cut off that
dependence now no longer
um it's independent of x2 in this
distribution but not this distribution
um and similarly
uh
so we'll get these or this orientation
we'll also get uh
the orientation between x2 and x3
um and that's because uh
uh if you
go back to the day one and day two we
talked about micros so these are kind of
these logical constraints that preserve
the
uh acyclicity of the dag and
like aim does not introduce any new b
structures so there's a meek roll that
tells us
you know this edge was unoriented
and then we look at x1 goes to x2
and then
well we can't orient it this way because
that would create a b structure between
x2 and x3
so we get
this oriented that way
and this is like a general phenomenon um
even if we have
multiple interventions
so if we
were to
have this variable also in intervene
here
now we wouldn't be able to tell
these two apart say that we just
knock both of these out set them to zero
there's kind of no way to tell
the causality between x1 and x2 but you
can still tell
x2 to x3
because otherwise you would be creating
the sp structure
[Music]
so this is kind of the argument that
allows us to conclude that
the v structures that are introduced by
our interventions
will exactly give us the edges between
variables that are in the intervention
set and variables that are not in the
intervention set
that's just written out here in terms of
if we have an edge
x i to x j in the first graph
and
uh only one of those variables is in the
intervention set
then that variable that edge also has to
be directed the same way in the second
graph for these two things to be more
complicated
uh can you please elaborate more on
why at five and have people service
why they are not equal
yeah so
maybe this is a uh
this is an issue of uh maybe what we
talked about on the second day of
faithfulness there are ways that you
could set this up so that they'd be
equal but in general you can choose a
distribution such that they are not
equal so say that x1
was uh you know bernoulli
and x2
was equal to like x1
plus or like
you know uh
xor with some other
let's say bernoulli
of x1 when we generate x2
so in general x2 tells you some
information about x1
right so the distribution of x1 given x2
could be given to you by bayes rule um
and you know you'd have higher
probability of x1 equaling
1 whenever x2 equals 1. but then if i
come in and i intervene on x2 and i say
okay x2 is always equal to one
now it doesn't tell you anything
about x1
i just want to understand how you draw
those zero variables yeah in this case
do you draw a zeta one go to x mod
or as in this case you draw just a
little one that goes to both yes
yeah so in this case it would just do
that this is just going to be the the
targets and the interventions
that i'm drawing the edges too i'm just
asking
such that it goes to every variable that
every variable in the intervention so
yeah the single zeta goes to every
variable
uh
right so this um
goes back to like this we have this
multi set of
um
or this collection of sets
right so
the number of interventions that i have
i'll draw that many variables
so when we're defining these fks these
different uh
interventions
uh yes
so what we know is uh you know from from
the definition of this
equivalence class is that certain
things that we don't intervene on these
the conditional probability
distributions stay the same but you know
like if i intervene
say on x2 and zeta 1 and i intervene
on x2 and
zeta 2
i'm not necessarily replacing these with
the same uh value i could and this one
replace it with one on this one replace
it with zero for
any other questions
uh
so yeah we'll just take this as an
example this is basically what i uh
wrote here except now i'm going to be
intervening on on this x3 variable just
to show that in general you can have the
still unidentified edges
this is a really good choice and this
one if we just intervene on x2 because
then we could have told the whole graph
let's say that we
you know we don't know what we're doing
in our vein on x3 instead
um in this case
the two graphs on the left have the same
b structures
and the same adjacencies whereas the
graph on the right uh doesn't have any b
structures so we'll be able to tell
these two graphs apart but not that
graph another way i like to think about
this is
um
in this case
zeta one
uh
affects x3 but kind of that effect
doesn't propagate so the marginal
distributions of x1 and x2
in both of these left graphs will remain
the same
but in general the marginal distribution
of x1 and x2 can change in the rightmost
graph
um so this leads us to the definition of
i essential graphs i think we called uh
these essential graphs
uh cp dags or complete partially
directed acyclic graphs in the other
lecture but that's a mouthful
like a conceptual question
i think when you interview on a note
what people are doing is to delete some
edges
right but now you're introducing more
notes and if any intervention is not
binary
but
how do you can tell which is then just
that you need to introduce accommodation
yeah so this is a kind of uh
i think of these interventions on like
an as needed basis it's like i'm if i'm
actually doing the intervention then
i'll introduce a node but i don't need
to introduce these intervention nodes
for
everything that could possibly be out
there like if these are continuous
variables that's required you know it's
like a continuous spectrum what is the
benefit of introducing new knowledge
um essentially just to make the
like one to make the reasoning a little
bit more similar to the reason that we
used about the separation in
the observational setting so if you look
at the original paper to define
interventional markov equivalents and
stuff
um
there's a few hoops that you have to
jump through if you're not going to
introduce
new nodes so it's basically a proof
technique
you cannot achieve the same thing by
deleting it
or removing edges yeah so so you can do
it with uh removing edges but that
doesn't happen generally in soft
interventions because the
so this is also a tool that's especially
useful in the setting of soft
interventions
um and i'll i'll briefly note um i
realized i actually never put it on the
slides um so if i
go all the way back to the kind of
different types of interventions
that we had i could have
added kind of another access or another
thing that you might worry about with
your interventions is that you might
have
uh
what they call these fat hand
interventions where you're trying to do
something you're trying to only affect
one node but you accidentally affect a
whole bunch of them so this is actually
a problem in uh gene regulatory networks
when we try to do knockout interventions
so just because of the
way the technology works there can be
uh
also interventions at other genes that
you don't know about a priority like
that's kind of not characterized so
beside your target gene so you can think
of also dealing with these bad hand or
like unknown target interventions and
adding in these intervention variables
also helps you deal with that because
you just treat them you treat the
problem of learning the intervention
targets
as kind of the same as learning that it
is
um
right so as i was discussing
uh this definition for i essential
graphs
um which is similar to
uh the
notion that we had in the observational
setting where we just look at the whole
um
markov equivalence class or in this case
the interventional markov equivalence
class
and
we kind of represent the information
that we have about it graphically so
what information do we have we know
all the things in the imark of
equivalence class have the same
adjacencies so our
by essential graph which is going to be
a mixed graph with both directed and
undirected edges will have the same
adjacencies as well
and then
if we know every graph in the markov
equivalence class has
a certain orientation of an edge then
we'll add that to the essential graph
otherwise we'll use these undirected
edges to indicate our uncertainty about
the direction of that edge
and these eye essential graphs are going
to kind of if you think of the
sequential setting that we'll talk about
later on they'll kind of be our
representative of our current
uncertainty
about what the true graph is
[Music]
uh it's more ambiguous than what
um
but you know where the error has gone
um this is the same as
you're introducing
um
not exactly so the i think you're
talking about kind of the one that's
augmented with those intervention
variables is that
to do right introduction the space of uh
central candidates
just reduces
yes the
definition of those um augmented graphs
included that that was based on what the
true deck was so that was augmenting the
tree guy with these variables
um this is
uh aiming at a different thing which is
um taking the whole collection of dags
and representing them in what way so you
could imagine um
leading in so this was the case that we
had on previous slide where these two
graphs were i markup equivalent when we
had the dimension on x3
and just based on the definition of this
this is this edge is the same between
them this is just difference that's why
that edges have directed you could
imagine
just leaving in
um the
intervention variable
so this is the same as like this would
be the
uh i essential graph or this would be
the essential graph
if you left in this intervention
variable
um but
because we're just kind of storing the
state of our knowledge about
the
relations between the system variables
and not the intervention variables we
just don't draw those in they don't
really matter
great
question um so
i'm going a little fast so i think this
section is actually pretty long so it's
good that we're starting it a little bit
early
um so i'll start off
probably before the
10 30 mark
by going through
uh the first two
non-adaptive experimental design
strategies
um and just to set up what case we're
gonna be in um so as i said we're gonna
be non-adaptive um
and then both of the algorithms that
i'll be looking at we'll assume that we
have no observational data so it's kind
of the most pessimistic setting
um where
you know your
bio grad student and your phd advisor
tells you you have to go out and you
have to do kind of
full identification
of the system but i'm not going to give
you any data
that's ever been measured about the
system you just have to kind of
completely design a set of experiments
that's going to completely identify
any possible system that's out there and
if you don't you know you don't graduate
yeah
the difference between no observational
data and observational data of one
trivial intervention like just running
in the adaptive setting yes because then
you could run the observe the trivial
intervention where you just gather
observational data
um
but
i think you'll see with these examples
that in the
non-adaptive setting
because it could be from any of the
markup equivalence classes
you would
um
you can't just do that one and then
decide all of your interventions after
it this is like a form of background
knowledge
that's a really good so yeah this this
last distinction doesn't matter as much
in the adaptive setting because you
could just
spend one intervention to get
observational data that intervention
being
don't intervene
so i might have missed this but
is this background
yeah this will take the form of an
essential graph so we have infinite
observational data and we can pinpoint
exactly
the markov equivalence class which is
represented by the essential graph
and i'm not doing more general
background knowledge
i'm only going to consider background
knowledge in the form of basically
infinite observational data
great so
uh i covered those three we're also i'm
going to start off this is going to be
the difference between the two
algorithms the first one i'll present
will be in the bounded setting um in
particular we'll actually only get lots
more node interventions and then we'll
go to the the unbounded setting for the
second
already so it's on the board because
i'll probably want
to use it
um so just as as a couple preliminaries
kind of
thinking back to the fact that we don't
have observational data um
we kind of already observed this fact
that if only one node in a
if only one node and edge is an
intervention then we'll be able to
obtain if if we know the two variables
are adjacent we'll be able to obtain
uh the direction of the adjacency
then this is usually not a problem in
the setting where we have observational
data because we already know all the
adjacencies but suppose that we don't
know all of
that we don't know all the adjacencies
already then we need
in order to establish the adjacency an
intervention where
both variables are not intervened um or
i'll show you can also determine it by
having one of these orientations tests
in one direction and one in the other
direction
so from frederick's phd thesis we have a
result that we'll use for both of these
strategies that
in order to determine both the presence
and absence or absence of an edge as
well as the orientation
um
these two conditions
are
sufficient
and in the worst case you need to
fulfill at least one of them
so the first condition
so this is kind of the condition that
we'll mostly be working with when we
have observational data is that we
need a structural adjacency test
which is fulfilled if we have
observational data and then we just need
a structural orientation test on one of
the variables
um
another way that we can obtain this
information
is by having an orientation test on each
of the variables so if you imagine
okay i have x
i
goes to xj
um
i want to determine this between
i want to determine between
these three possible graphs
so can i do this
if i have an intervention
on each of these variables so if i
introduce this zeta one
zeta two
[Music]
um if i introduce it to all of these
right then
um
we'll be able to
tell between all of them because of this
v structure so there we'll have a v
structure at x j in this case and x i in
this case
and we'll have
nothing down here
um can we do it without
uh
either one of these interventions so can
we neglect one of them say i just want
to do
zeta two
um well if i'm using a do intervention
on this graph
then after intervention this looks
exactly the same as this bottom graph
because i've cut off the edge between
them
so this kind of clarify why
um
one of these is
having one of these is sufficient but
it's also in the worst case going to be
necessary
sorry can you just clarify the
difference between
orientation testing the structural
orientation test yeah this is uh
they should have edited this before it's
just uh orientation testing either
exotic or exchange
um so starting off with single node
interventions
we'll ask ourselves okay how many
single node interventions are sufficient
and in the worst case going to be
necessary so this is the thing i was
telling you about you know your advisor
says you have to discover it
um i don't care you know use the minimal
number of interventions but if you don't
discover it like
you don't graduate
um and
if just to kind of clarify between all
the different setups that we're going to
consider i'll write them as these
optimization problems so here
we're trying to do is minimize the size
of the intervention set
such that
for all g
not in like anything just all g over p
nodes say
um the graph well like where the
interventions will identify that graph
and then for all of the
interventions in this set the size of
the intervention is very cool
um
and uh kind of maybe unsurprisingly in
this case it's pretty pessimistic it's
going to require
p minus one intervention
um so to go through
uh the proof of sufficiency
um of it's not too surprising that this
is sufficient maybe you'll
see why don't we have to do every single
variable
um
so
the kind of scheme that we're using here
is to um
say that we have these like five
variables
we'll just
i mean it's kind of obvious we want to
do a separate intervention
we don't want to kind of intervene on
the same node twice ever
so we'll pick one variable
not to do the intervention on
um
and then
okay we want to check
whether the conditions
um from the
previous slide here are satisfied
so first we can observe that
all pairs of variables will be subject
to
one of these adjacency tests so there
will be one intervention where they do
not occur
um
so yeah just take an intervention
um
if you want for x1 and x2 take the
intervention of x3 that will be
provide the structural adjacency test
for those
um
and then all pairs of these variables
will have at least one member
um that's going to serve as kind of the
orientation test so
uh
the only thing that you really have to
worry about is in this case the variable
that you don't intervene on but because
you've intervened on every other
variable
um that's going to be your orientation
test
now um okay is that really the best we
can do
yes if we don't know the graph
um kind of the most pessimistic thing
is that we intervene on all but two of
the variables but the two that we don't
intervene on happen to be the most
upstream so this is
um you know say these are our
interventions we intervene on x3 x4 and
x5
and then i just have in
these different colors kind of what
edges you learn
from each of them just by that kind of
uh
orientation test rule
[Music]
what you don't get is
the edge between x1 and x2 because if
you think
back to the migrals kind of none of them
allow you to orient something that's
upstream of yourself none of these
different interventions will be able to
tell you
um anything about whether x1 is
affecting x2 or x2 is affecting x1
the previous example for two nodes it
seems that you need two interventions
um
yes i think this needs a quantifier of
p greater than or equal to three or
something
the the
the question here should be p variable
yeah there's no so the question was um
we're assuming in this setting
that there's
no observational data and no other kind
of background knowledge about the graph
yeah
yeah so so we are assuming that the true
system is a dag positive
all right so
last few minutes i'll go through the uh
getting all these other things fixed uh
now just the unbounded case
and we'll see
um
a logarithmic
uh
dependence instead of
the linear dependence on the number of
nodes
what is the difference between
intervening
every single variable
separately versus defining form one
umbrella intervention
that changes the value of multiple names
yeah um this is a good point so
the question was what's the difference
between
doing like p-interventions where i
intervene on every single in each
intervention i only intervene on one
variable and then doing
uh one intervention where in that
intervention i intervene on key
variables so in the case where you
intervene on p variables imagine the do
operations that type of intervention
where i'm setting it to a specific value
then
you know my actual distribution when i
do a
when i do that intervention on all the
variables at once it's just going to be
you know point mass at whatever the
thing i said to it's deterministically
going to be a certain quantity
versus if i do it all separately there's
still variability in all the variables
that i don't
intervene on so in particular you know
this is
uh
this is kind of the tricky thing of
why
in this
structural um
orientation test we need
uh that we can only identify between
variables where one is in the
distribution or one is in the
intervention and when it's not in the
intervention
because if i just intervene on
everything and cut all of the dependents
it has kind of no relation to the
original system so i can't tell anything
about the the edges between these
variables
does that answer your question
in an alternative world you have x1 x2
and x3 but you're interviewing among x1
and x2 separately
yeah there
so here again
if you have one distribution where you
interview on x1 and one where you
intervene on x2
um
and the one where you intervene only on
x1
if say x2 is a child of x1 then you'll
still have x2 being
dependent on x1
um
and
i guess not vice versa but
uh because they won't both be
children of each other um
in this distribution x1 and x2 will be
rather independent
so you won't be able to tell anything
about the orientation
so
maybe i'll
kind of
uh
yeah i think i have time to walk through
this result so
uh
this is the same optimization problem
you'll see is on the previous slide just
without the constraint on the individual
interventions that are in this
intervention set
um
and let's start by proving
uh that you can get by with this many
interventions so i'll give you an actual
way of picking the interventions that
um
[Music]
will completely identify
any graph
so it's based on this trick of kind of
numbering the nodes and taking binary
representations of them
so
i'm using this to denote the binary
representation and then i'm subscripting
to kind of tell you what uh
actual position i'm going to be looking
at so if we take
the binary expansion of 6 it's going to
be like 1 1 0
and then
and
the indexes start from the right so
b6 1 is going to be 0 and then b6 of 2
is going to be 1.
um so the idea is to label the vertices
from 0 to p minus 1. so i'll start at
zero
and then i'll let my intervention be
composed of
all of the variables
uh
that have a one
in
so i'll pick
a floor of
uh log p
plus one interventions and i'll
let uh every single intervention be
defined by just looking at the different
nodes and seeing which ones are
uh zero or one and if it's a one i'll
include it um so as a example this is on
uh
eight nodes and i've started from zero
um like i said you should and then
if you
kind of think about this um this is
basically you know kind of doing some
mod operations so
uh here i'm the first thing is going to
be on all the odd numbers
um and then the second thing is going to
be
um
basically
you know do 0 0 and then
i'll do 1 1
0 0 1 1 so i'll
keep alternating
and increasing powers of 2
which variables are going to be the
targets of the intervention
and this final one is going to be on the
the last four variables
and in this case
because
i chose floor of log
base 2 of p
in this case there's eight variables so
there's
that's three the four just remains the
same i get four interventions so i'll
have this extra one intervention
um that doesn't hit anything because
all of the
like zero through seven if you take
their binary expansions aren't going to
have anything at the fourth kind of
rightmost position
so why does this work
the first thing to notice is that
because each of the binary expansions of
these different numbers is different
there's going to be at least one
intervention at the spot where they're
different that includes one but not the
other so we're guaranteed to get at
least one of these orientation tests
um
if p is the power of two this is pretty
easy so
you'll have that empty intervention out
there that gives your you your adjacency
test for all parents
and then if p is not a power of two um
it's a little trickier to analyze but
not too bad so
the fact that
p is not a power of two
means that uh every number is going to
have at least one zero in this binary
expansion because if i had all ones
then
i would have to be going up to
you know in this case
uh the binary expansion of seven
is all ones i would have to be going up
to
uh in my numbering
uh
right below the the power of two
so all of them are going to have a zero
in their binary expansion
um
and then
i have to ask myself okay
i have my
structural orientation test
now i need either
um an adjacency test or
the opposite kind of structural
orientation test
um so let's say
uh you know for sake of contradiction
that there was a pair of variables
where we didn't have either of those so
let's start with saying that we didn't
have
um
the
adjacency test so where they're both
zeros
um
in that case so i write out
uh
one of my numbers i know that they're
say this is the first number um
a1 and a2
i know that they have a difference here
and then i
uh just by the fact that they're
different i'll take a1 to be the one
with a 1 in this position without loss
of generality and then
uh i know that
i've said all
there are no um like wherever these are
zero
um this will not correspondingly be zero
if i'm assuming that there's no
adjacency tests so these have to be one
and then
if i assume that they
are also
no zeros in this one so none of these
opposing ones then these also have to
all be one
and then i achieve the contradiction of
having um
this number actually has to be all ones
whereas i said that all of them have at
least one zero in there
and then uh so we're
a couple minutes past time so we'll do
the uh proof of the fact that this is
in the worst case necessary
after the break
okay great thank you um we're going to
take a break out as usual until uh 11.
see you all bye
oh